Angela Merkel was tight-lipped about the
Bavarian election result as she greeted
young campaigners for her Christian
Democratic Union for Merkel the success
of her Bavarian allies the Christian
social Union means she can likely count
on for 25 million votes in Bavaria on
Sunday but the CDU's junior coalition
partner the fdp didn't make the five
percent threshold in Bavaria that's why
we're concentrating on the national
election results that's what counts now
it's about the whole country and it
needs a strong liberal party the SPD
vote in Bavaria was up only slightly but
the opposition party is spinning the
result as a tailwind for the federal
election party leaders called for a
last-minute push to get out the vote a
mix until next Sunday the election will
be decided on turnout if it reaches 75%
or above then pair Steinbrueck will be
Chancellor and will govern with the
greens but the Greens vote share in
Bavaria was down and pulls indicate they
are also faltering nationally this heist
it's phones that means we now have to do
everything we can before Sunday to make
clear once more just how crucial this
election is with the center right and
center left blocks polling neck and neck
many now believe the most likely outcome
of Sunday's vote is a grand coalition
between the CDU and the SPD